hello everyone my name is bradley and my
name is emily and this is some sub a
channel about avoiding the predators
lurking in the online jungle man began
to spy on others through the keyhole
pretty much the same day he invented the
log curiosity is an inherent part of our
nature and thanks to the development of
digital technologies spying on other
people has become easier than ever
before look here one simple request and
i can literally look into someone else's
life
so obviously this is a regular google
search page but with a little of
google's magic
and here in front of me is a list of web
cameras connected to the network see how
simple it is i mean here's a panorama of
some city here's a classroom and well
that's just someone's ordinary room but
you know this hack in particular has
been going on for years i'm actually
quite surprised that there are still web
cameras on the network that can be found
using this query
but how does it all work in fact it's
extremely simple in the query i
indicated that i need pages with a
combination of the characters of webcam
xp5 and the header this is the same as
an old program that manages webcams and
in particular allows you to connect to
them via a web interface i can actually
find out where these web cameras are
located you see how they have external
ip addresses well if you search for this
address through a special website for
example dnschecker.org
then in a second you can actually find
out that this picturesque city is
located in serbia not bad eh
and now a more cool trick if i type one
more complex query into the search bar
[Music]
can you guess what i'm looking for well
of course you can passwords to other
people's databases now in files with the
env extension some web developers
actually store variables for their
programs the most important pair of
variables is the username and password
for accessing the database see i now
know how to connect to the database of
some uzbek site
[Music]
and yes i'm now a real hacker
[Music]
fortunately not everything is so simple
to actually use this password i'll have
to somehow run my script on the same
server
but this information can be the first
step to really hacking the system what
i've just shown you is called google doc
queries now these are queries that use
standard google tools to search for
holes in the security systems of web
resources search algorithms constantly
scan the internet and remember pretty
much everything they see
attackers or just curious users only
need to make the right queries in order
to get access to other people's secrets
you can experiment with google docs
yourself or use ready-made queries for
example those that are found on my
favorite site exploit database
exclusively for educational purposes of
course but i'm going to leave the search
for holes in the security of websites
for another time for i am interested in
another question how much do all of
these search engines that remember
everything they see threaten living
people
how much can actually tell other people
about each one of us what can i tell you
about emily moore
well first when you're a teenager you
had the same charming smile
here's the proof and while we're
speaking about smiles did you know that
you met joe biden through just two
handshakes that's right yes it's correct
look the dentist to whom you owe your
smile has been working on the teeth of
the future american ambassador to
ukraine for several years i suspect
you're rooting for mercier lynx a youth
hockey team and one of your friends even
won a bronze medal at the european
championships in this sport now probably
won't surprise you that i know your
phone number and even your home address
too from this and i learned all of this
from open sources so today we're going
to talk about open source intelligence
or osint for short
[Music]
the concept of austin actually appeared
at the height of the second world war in
february of 1941 president roosevelt
ordered the creation of a new
intelligence unit the foreign broadcast
monitoring service fbms specialists had
the task of listening to open broadcasts
of us opponents and through analyzing
propaganda news releases and even
ordinary broadcasts they reconstructed
the true state of the industry
infrastructure and armed forces of the
axis countries initially only 150 000
was allocated for the development of the
service but it soon proved its
effectiveness it turned out that
information open sources can tell us a
lot for example there was a direct link
between the prices of oranges in paris
and the condition of road and railway
bridges each bombardment of these
objects during the nazi occupation of
france caused problems with the delivery
of tender fruits if prices were rising
then the missions of the allied bombers
were proving successful lieutenant
general samuel v wilson who headed up
the defence intelligence agency in the
70s claims that he received 90 of
intelligence data from open sources
the real heroes of intelligence were not
special agents like james bond but
rather analysts like sherlock holmes is
it really any wonder that now we can
access an incredible amount of open
information via the internet now it's
time for you and i to master osint tools
fortunately they're now available to
anyone who has an internet browser
[Music]
do you remember the video in which i was
looking for the information about the
viewers of the sum sub channel if not be
sure to watch it later it's a great
video but look in it i deliberately
didn't use special search tools limiting
myself effectively to standard google
tools today i'm going to take it to the
next level and i'm going to check how
much information the network can
actually store about a particular person
and my victim will be my co-host emily
and now i'm actually going to find out
the whole truth about her so what did i
know about you before i started my
investigation well of course your name
if your parents would have called you
something like in the style of elon musk
then i wouldn't even have to try a
person with the name like x-a-12 is
pretty difficult to confuse with someone
else but you have a very common first
and last name emily moore and therefore
simple search is almost impossible to
find you you'd have to sort through tens
of thousands of different people i mean
look here's your namesake artist here's
an author of children's books right
another emily moore has a sensational
story about voluntary organ donation
thank god that's not you therefore it's
useless to search for you by name there
are just too many options i need some
kind of unique identifier now we
discussed our last shoot via telegram so
i've got that and i've also got your
email because that's where i sent your
script to and in telegram your nickname
is m99
now this looks pretty much like your
initials in year of birth right in the
video about passwords i already said
that 59 of users use their real data for
authorization
but in the gmail name use a slightly
different principle
emilymore74
now the numbers in the name slightly
strained me i mean that could be
anything the number of your room number
and your student halls the beginning or
end of the home phone number maybe the
house number the main thing is that it
shouldn't be a pin code from a bank card
right but so far this is just a guess
now if i were looking for information
about emily manually i would start with
the osint framework website as you can
see this page contains links of dozens
of services that help collect
information about a person's site or
company based on already available data
now with their help it's easy to add the
portrait of any person that we're
analyzing if i already know the user's
name in some social network for instance
then the first thing i would do is check
where else they're registered none of us
have had time to maintain all of our
social media profiles right and
therefore by analyzing which networks a
person spends the most time in i can
draw a conclusion about his or her
interests and even evaluate their
professional qualifications for example
a profile on github will be important
for any programmer if a person and i
would like to call them a victim
actually is interested in the internet
of things most likely they'll be
registered on the ifttt website and a
designer or a photographer might be
using divine tarts or pinterest we might
also find unexpected hobbies for example
on twitch or information about the
cities and countries they visited
foursquare can help for that the
repeated use of the same name on
different services allows anyone to come
one step closer to creating your perfect
physiological portrait and therefore if
you're really worried about your privacy
try to use different names but also
don't duplicate unique information on
your profiles
i mean for instance if you've been to
the north pole you're fond of creating
ships in bottles and you speak english
and chinese well this information is
more than enough to match different
profiles with different names
so look let's test this theory in
practice so i know emily's personal
email and therefore i'm gonna check on
which sites users with the same nickname
were registered
[Music]
so i've got two different nicknames that
emily has used it's emily
99 in telegram and emily
or in gmail in fact this actually gives
us three identifiers google assigns each
user a hidden code it actually consists
of 20 digits now it's impossible to get
it directly theoretically but i'm going
to show you how to do it now and google
also will help in this rather hangouts
is the company's own messenger and to
find out emily's secret id i'll run a
search with her nickname and then i'll
open the text of the page in developer
mode look you see this parameter this id
or emily is openly passed in it for
google's internal services your name is
one one six five six and so on what does
this information actually give well look
i can actually see a few posted photos
for google maps a simple request and
alas i see that you haven't done that
okay look i'm going to save these
numbers for memory and maybe come back
to them a bit later but now i'm going to
deal with open names the fastest way to
check them is through the site's name
checker or what's my name they basically
check whether the answered names are
available for popular internet resources
now already based on this data i can say
that you're right about your security
the name of your mailbox is not used on
other sites but use the nickname from
telegram much more often i actually
found five matches in this case by the
way telegram has bots that identify
phone numbers by username but this is
completely legal so forget i told you
that
well look it's a start but now i need to
study all of these matches found i need
to analyze which of them actually relate
to the person i'm interested in and
which do not but also i need to find
possibly additional information here for
example mentions of previous jobs
educational institutions reviews of
hotel rooms perhaps and so on
information is never and never can be
superfluous then i would manually check
the new facts maybe i could find out
information about emily's ip address or
get gps coordinates from the metadata of
uploaded photos i've already talked
about working with this data in a video
about the mistakes of famous criminals
okay let's take a step back here do you
not surprise me when i actually checked
your policies so they're not on facebook
and i can't believe you've never used
them but it's too difficult to search
among a couple of billion users for a
single emily it's gonna take much more
than one week to check thousands of
results and therefore i'm gonna try and
remember which cities or companies you
mentioned during the last filming
session now you said you went to uni in
manchester so i'm going to try and find
an emily moore on facebook that is
connected with the city and bingo
among the first options i recognized
your face and also perhaps facebook
itself played along with me as there
were records in this database that we
were in the same location at the same
time and this is enough to put you in
the first few lines of the search
results but these are just my paranoid
assumptions anyway now i know another
one of your online pseudonyms emily.more
dot
one if your photo wasn't here it'd
probably take me a long time to find it
so let's look at the profile you hid
your friends but you made a popular
mistake their names remain visible under
the comments to your photos so i
actually got a list of two people who
are definitely part of your entourage
this is alice
the champion from mercier lynx and also
david moore david is the more secretive
of them he only has two profile pictures
and one of them has you in it this photo
was taken 2013 when you were assuming
that you were born in 99 only 14 years
old now david himself is much older i
checked his picture on the website
pictreeev.com and the service estimated
his age at 45 that is he should be about
55 now he's hardly your brother right
the age difference is too great so i'd
assume he's your father or your uncle
right you'll be writing the money there
he's my dad there we go but look what's
the danger of revealing information
about close relatives or friends well
attackers can actually use this
information about loved ones for
phishing attacks by effectively
simulating an appeal from doctors the
police or creating a fake profile
facebook is generally an ideal tool for
finding people you just need to look
carefully at what it shows for example
this photo here seems absolutely
harmless right it's unknown when and
where it was taken there are no clues in
the frame signatures or metadata but
this is not the case i used a search for
similar photos and found that god's own
junkyard is a curious place just north
of london and it's also easy to look for
connections between different people on
facebook you recently wrote a review and
mentioned the name of a dentist you saw
a few months ago on the clinics page i
found not only the contact details of
this very dentist her full name is
santella shatirishvili but look the
clinic has posted a slideshow in which
your dentist poses with a thank you
letter from bridget brink her name is
easy to find on any information site a
few days ago joe biden proposed as the
new us ambassador to ukraine a curious
chain i think not
but to be honest
i'm lazy at heart maybe for the first or
second time in my life such data
analysis would come with great
enthusiasm from my part but for the 10th
or 100th time of using it only brings me
bored and therefore i'm going to suggest
that you dig into the possibilities of
open resources yourself and i myself
will opt for a more serious tool and
here you can't make do with just one
browser
[Music]
so i installed multego now this is a
powerful software package that has long
been the arsenal of any professional
hacker for example in kali linux it is
immediately included in the distribution
now today i'm using windows computer so
i'll have to download it from the
website of the same name you'll actually
find a link to it in the description of
this video i don't want to spend extra
money on this entertainment yet so i'm
going to use the free version of the
program for this example community
edition is limited in search depth and
as a rule it gives only the most popular
answers to the query i'm interested in
the number of objects in it is limited
to 10 000 and of course it cannot be
used for commercial purposes but for the
first time using the software multigo ce
is quite a suitable option now if we are
to draw an analogy with the real world
multigo is most like a board with the
results of an investigation from a cool
detective right we'll be able to place
the collected evidence on the main work
screen and the program will help us to
build connections between them for
example for a specific person these may
be profiles in social networks
highlighted phone numbers and email
addresses maybe even articles with
mentions to them on the internet and so
on by the way do you remember i said
that bitcoin is not anonymous in a
previous video but look here even in the
basic version of the program several
modules available for analyzing payments
and building chains of connections
between different crypto wallets but
let's return for a minute to search for
information about a particular person
some of the services in the free version
are available with restrictions and some
require additional authorization and
obtaining a key from the project's
partners multego is effectively a meta
shelf that allows you to automate
routine information retrieval processes
but we're gonna have to think in exactly
the same way as we would if we were
analyzing through the onset framework
now let's see what the protagonist of
our video thinks about my investigation
what was i right about where did i make
mistakes and where did i miss important
details
oh um what about you your name is there
any any reasons why your parents called
you emily perhaps if you'd been able to
find a little bit of information about
my mom you would know that she is a
teacher
and her biggest challenge when choosing
my name was picking a name that she
hadn't had a child she had already
taught and grown to passionately dislike
so she chose emily because she'd never
taught any emilies and therefore she
still liked the name
even the part about your friend winning
a bronze medal yep my oldest friend is a
semi-professional hockey player
wow and did you know that you know joe
biden through just two handshakes not at
all was i right about the manchester
thing
you're right i did go to uni in
manchester but i'm not from manchester
originally
i'm glad to see you weren't able to find
my birthplace anywhere on the internet
yet but did you know that your uh
dentist was actually a sort of big shot
dentist no i didn't she's a great
dentist but i knew nothing about her
other clients so look so we we actually
know more about you than you know about
you which is kind of crazy quite scary
so what's god's own junkyard like pretty
cool it's a nice free place that you can
spend a bit of time in london so can you
buy drinks there or is it like a
restaurant or what is it they might have
a coffee shop i don't know i was just
there for the pictures cool that was fun
and um i noticed that clinic was
actually in georgia so i've got a quick
question what were you doing in georgia
um i was taking a working holiday i
spent a month in georgia but back in
london now so i suppose the biggest
question here is were you surprised by
the amount of information we could dig
up
just from open sources
yeah i absolutely was
things like my dad maybe i'm not that
surprised about but more
more details about my friends what they
do
my dentist for example
shows i'm leaving a much larger online
footprint than i realized well look the
interface of this program does need some
getting used to we need to be in mind
that this is a professional behind the
curtain kind of tool but i really plan
to master it these modules are
undeniably intriguing and i want to know
what kind of power they're actually
hiding and whether or not they're worth
the money and therefore i plan to
practice our sint investigations on my
colleagues and then i'll return to this
topic with new knowledge about the
features of the paid version guys from
paterva if you're watching this video
bear that in mind once again i've been
convinced that there is information
about pretty much everything on the
internet and if you just can't find
something or you don't know how to
search for it in any case my name is
bradley and my name name's emily and
this is some sub and also if you want
some fancy alliteration from us you
better squeeze it out of me using
awesome and i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
you